um and then i guess nick drake is this
guy um
so nick drake is like
he so he's like kind of he plays folk
music
as if you couldn't tell from this
picture
um but he uh he basically it's really
hard to describe him
so he he basically he killed himself
very early in his career okay um i think
he was like 23 24
um but he made this one album called
pink moon
and it's like it's literally just him
and a guitar yeah that's it and it's
like super low-fi it's just it's just
him just like singing
just one guitar occasionally maybe like
a piano but like it's so like it's one
of like look like when it comes to like
depression
like as a theme in music yeah a lot of
artists have done it yeah from like all
sorts of different angles in my opinion
pink moon is probably the most [ __ ]
hard-hitting and like real album when it
comes to like depression and exploring
what makes you say that
it's because like it's not only just
like the tone of his singing
and just the fact that it's just him and
a guitar yeah but it's again it's like
lyrics obviously yeah um he has this one
song called um
uh i think it's called black dog um and
it inspired a book called black dog it's
like depression is like a black dog it
just like keeps coming back and like
that's from the song that he wrote um
but it's like i don't know it's like
it's beautiful but it's like
haunting it's like really really [ __ ]
haunting and like every time i play this
album like there's just like a couple of
songs that i just hit where i'm just
like breakdown crying i guess because
you know the you know what how real the
stuff is when someone's in that state of
mind you know sometimes
it's like you sometimes you can't always
express yourself or communicate that
emotion without having a medium like
music or some something like that like
what i can say is that like nick drake
is music but what it's certainly not is
entertainment
right it is old oh yes
it is
i would dare say it it really is the
awesome it is just like it is music in
its purest artistic form yeah where it's
like you don't put on a nick drake album
to [ __ ] jam out you put on a nick
drake album to like
self-reflect and like you know just kind
of take it in yeah and like you know
kind of learn from it right because like
he was like he was super depressed like
i'm talking like mega mega mega
depressed from a child yeah and like i
mean i believe that yeah and uh you know
and like it led him to take his own life
you know he was like extremely [ __ ]
talented he probably had a bright future
ahead of him if he kept going but yeah
depression he's very hard to deal with
yeah so he just kind of like gained a
cult status because of that and my
sister actually like put me on to nick
drake um because i guess she was in like
a stage in her life where she kind of
was like
yeah and i was like i feel like i found
him in like the perfect time and again
like this is not an artist i would
recommend to people who want bangers
well like i feel like that type of music
or that type of media definitely has a
place because especially like when you
are in a dark place
sometimes you're not looking for like
happy music or like things to cheer you
up but like listening to i guess someone
who has been in that same emotional
state yeah or maybe finding someone who
you feel is in that same emotional state
as you yes there's like a comfort
knowing that at least you're not like
the only one who's feeling like yeah and
when i was in that like
moment in my life as well and listening
to nick drake i think this album cheered
me up more than any [ __ ] album yeah
it's it's weird because when i'm really
depressed and really sad
listening to depressing music cheers me
up yeah like it's it's it's like
listening to happy music just makes me
more depressed yeah because i'm just
like how does how like why are they
happy and i'm not how dare this beat
like be this like upbeat and like happy
how dare these people be happy you
listen to the pressing songs and i'm
just like [ __ ] man i'm not i'm not alone
i'm not the only one i'm not exactly
yeah yeah exactly yeah like that's the
thing it's like i feel listening to
happy music while depressed just does
the opposite effect because it makes you
go how come they're happy but i'm not
yeah yeah you know i can't relate to
this happy mood right now because that's
not where i am
right now i'm in this [ __ ] dark
depressing like somber moment
and i need something that can like you
know compliment that feeling yeah um so
that's why i love nick drake um and then
yeah i talked about mf2 american
football uh so they're pretty much i
think they're a recent like addition to
like my favorite bands but uh they made
me fall in love with this genre of music
called midwest emo
what
what
there is a genre of music called midwest
emo you know people say genres out loud
yeah i just think you're just lying
like i just like you know you like at
this point like
i feel like music most of all like
people just make up genres oh yeah of
course
it's music most of all yeah of course of
course they do they're just like it's
not punk it's it's just some derivative
of punk we don't want to be the same as
those punk bands so so what's so good
about them
okay so
it's emo
country no midwest midwest midwest
how did you define midwest it's midwest
uh it is emo made by bands who have
lived in the midwest america so what is
the difference between midwest emo and
emo
okay so in terms of sound is there a
southern emote
i'm sure there is but i wouldn't be
aware of it uh so midwest emo is like so
basically these guys founded the genre
um and like the indie scene for the past
like 20 years has been just filled with
midwest emo bands
um
yeah
and yeah they're like they're like
there's a lot of bands who have gotten
big off like band camp and like
soundcloud and like spotify and stuff
that are in this genre
um and it's like
how do i explain midwest it's like
it's like indie rock and math rock with
folk music
what is meth rock i see this is where i
don't understand math rock now this is a
problem because like every time i i
speak people who really know music you
start saying things to me i'm like
you're just
you're just lying like why isn't that on
on itunes that thing am i stupid like it
is on itunes it probably is now but like
to me it's like are we categorizing
music too much
i mean i guess but that's because i feel
music just in general has expanded to so
yeah so far that like it's just like
it's kind of a shame to just throw it
all away it's just rock
that's true i guess maybe this is just
my own inability to understand it and so
i'm just like why yeah well i mean you
know it's the same thing with like
electronic music right like you have
electronica you have house you have
trance you have yeah i guess so where
whereas like someone who doesn't like
music will be like it's just all
electronica it's just the beeps and the
boobs it's just the beeps and the boobs
right so
so midwest emo is like it's as the name
suggests a lot of the lyrical themes are
very depressing
um but it's not like folk music like
strictly it's not like a nick drake it's
like there's there's a band behind it
usually a lot of songs can be upbeat
but usually the lyrical contents are
very depressing hence the emo so that
makes it emo when it's depressing yeah
okay it's kind of like it's kind of like
emo
this is gonna sound really bad it
midwest emo is like
is like nick drake if you were
privileged
[Laughter]
like like if you were like if you like i
don't know if that's a hot topic if
you're like
if you're if you you know you're going
into like so many layers right now it's
like midwest demo is like it's coming
from bands who like have lived in like
the midwest in small towns where like
it's not like they're born into like
poverty or like just kind of yeah it's
just like they kind of just like lived
in a town that's in the middle of
nowhere in the midwest not a whole lot
to do except get sad about [ __ ] okay
because they don't you know because they
have like because you're from like
minnesota
yeah yeah yeah it is like suburban emo
that's the only way i just made that up
it is
it is it is i just made a new genre of
music right now there's emo rock yeah
with mixes of folk music for people who
live in suburban midwest areas i think i
understand yeah terrible yeah
yes
paramore kind of took midwest emo sound
and put a little bit more of like a punk
twist on it yeah right so they're a
little more like upbeat right but
they're still like you know the lyrical
context of like paramore songs are still
very much like you know like i'm feeling
depressed because this girl doesn't like
me and she left me and you know i was
like my town has nothing my friends have
all moved away that kind of stuff yeah
yeah so like so american football is
that um and through american football i
found like i like so you know how
spotify has that like spotify
midwest email was number two for me last
year
um and like american football was like a
big reason for that wow because i just
listened to a lot of american football
like not just american football there's
like a lot of other like midwest emails
and i basically just found this like
large pool of midwest emo bands and
they're all [ __ ] amazing what appeals
to you about midwest emo
yeah
that's such a random like it is right
such a random genre of music it's um i
don't know
for one like the music is just good like
it sounds good um it's like performed
well like uh because it's like got
blends of math rock which is like very
like technical rock and like technical
guitar okay okay i just love that sound
in general like japan does a lot of
really good mouth rock like japan japan
has its own like branch of metal called
japanese math rock and like japan is
like really [ __ ] good to just like
you know like like okay
for instance right like the you know
like the opening psychopaths the first
time yeah yeah yeah that's master
where it's like very technical guitar
and it's just like very like whaley fair
enough um but midwest emo kind of takes
a lot of that style of just like
technical guitar which just as a
guitarist i can appreciate for once like
one thing i always want to know is like
how much do you appreciate
music in like a technical sense or like
a theory sense where oh obviously you're
like way more musical trained musically
trained than yeah i am um
so like how much does that play into
your taste in music or your appreciation
music in general i mean you know if i
hear something i'm just like oh
what did he just do there then obviously
i'm gonna like poke my ears up right but
like i'm not gonna fall in love with a
band just because they're technical
right because again at the end of the
day if your music isn't good then it's
not good right and you know i've
listened to a lot of like midwest emo
and like even like metal like technical
metal bands and stuff like that where
i'm like yeah you're technical you are
skilled yeah but the music isn't really
for me kind of right right